كيف تلقى صدام حسين الرئيس العراقي الاسبق
نبا مقتل نجليه وحفيده
وحكى لي هاي القصه قال كنت اني احد
المواطنين العراقيين من الاصدقاء
يعني كان كان عامل الغداء حتى نتغدى
كان وضعها يعني يعني
ليش ارتباك قال له والله اني يعني سيدي
اني مخفي عليك خبر قال له خير قال عدي
استشهد
وقصي استشهد يقول قلت له عفيتين قال لو
مصطفى ايضا استشهد
فحكى له الواقع انه عمليه مقاومه مداهمه
والاولاد الله يرحمهم يعني ابناء اقامه
حفيده قاموا القوات الامريكيه ومصطفى نزل
قصي نعم الوكيل
كانت وشايه ايضا نعم كانت وشايه من الشخص
اللي اللي استضافهم الداره وطبعا بماذا
الاموال اولا هو صفه الغدر يعني موجوده
يعني هي صفه للاسف يعني في بعض الاشخاص هي
غريزية هو مش قريبهم كان يدعي انه انه
يعني من عشيرتهم وكان يعني محاط بعنايتهم
ومحاط برعايه خاصه علاقه قديمه
واثروا عليه بالمال واثره علي يعني بكل
النعم اللي موجوده
بالاخير طبعا الفلوس اللي معاهم هم طبعا
عليها وطبعا
بال 25 مليون اللي اعطوه اياه القوات
الامريكيه 25 مليون دولار
يعني مكافاه